mark what is the best thing about the
best thing about Chris Christie and I'm
not making a joke about his size what
I'm saying sir the guy feels the room he
really really does he knows how to work
a room and it's we call it in politics
retail politics but it's incredibly
important skill in early states like
Iowa New Hampshire still is really
endears you to voters he talks like a
regular person job you have a
conversation chris Christie are not
talking with a politician or talking
with someone who still are in and goes
on and despite as I talk to people yeah
and he always knows reporters he knows
everybody's name he's always pointing at
them to argue with them and you know and
and look he's losing weight so so if
even if you want to make the joke he's
filling is filling the room a lot less
yeah I mean you know so uh but no he
really just these presence is is a bit
when he is talking with Republican they
like him in person he really as a
campaigner young is the magnetic charm
about him is that also partly a jersey
thing like he's a big guy from Jersey it
has like a little bit uh Tony Soprano he
doesn't care who he's arguing with like
I think I think there's some of that I
mean just you know it just is it just is
who he is I think in an era when people
want their politicians to talk more like
regular people and kind of sick of
Washington speak uh and particularly you
know what politicians who aren't
necessarily beholding to an ideology and
are running on let's get things done
yeah let's get things done enough stuff
isn't getting done you know chris
Christie he just he fits the ideal yeah
put his arm around President Obama so
and and repeal breeze right and look
Republican base the elite Republican
base hates him for that will never
forgive him for that but you could argue
you know as just as a human being that
was the best thing he ever did yeah I
mean it was the right thing to do he may
have sacrificed a part of his political
future because of it but you know it
shows you the man's character apart